e un tipo pisano che ha tesoro c'è ma
dove cazzo madre natura pensa sembrano
ma perché non si fa poi casa bellissima
sono molto contento di iniziare questo
video su house party house party tu non
sai che cosa sono all'oscuro
completamente di tutto lui glielo spiego
ragazzi alla di come uno spartito sparti
un gioco un po si parte ok c'è un party
a casa di madison questa sera è stato
invitato dal tuo amico de re partiamo da
un richiamo del falchi tratta di un po
triste questo martini è un pò triste
vedere che questa nostra mi code lungo
tempo per riparlarne signorina allora la
signora jacqueline signorina ashley cole
a due grandi motivazioni per essere
onesta 6 che sono io
noi ok basta 21 di azione ai match sono
dassisti ster di mei melo non va bene o
più più con ashley attenzione io lei
tarsi volete rapporto che animazione di
pesca qua arriva da un sacco di ge
patrick non puoi dire questa merda siamo
molto più che ben hanno litigando
litigato
la city la zia ma amica mi la zia la zia
signora sia la zia aria gara sia calma
sia casa mi dispiace cos'è successo so
cosa hai fatto parte ma che doveva
ragionare così la maglietta sarà
vagliato neo lasca per non fare la pasta
bottiglia è sparita va bene a parte bene
questa fase medusa che lo genera lavora
come stai
[Musica]
ma poi tutti a casa e si sa mai ma sei
pazzo
questo è pazzo ma tutto bene e scherza
non siamo morti
ma era una festa un incontro mma scusami
facciamo l'altro questa era giusto per
darti una minima idea di come si fa a
day night with britney magari non so chi
sia britney che lo facciamo senza fretta
senza maledetto frank maledetta finale
fra le feste sono le tre membri a chi ma
infatti ma poi subito così non anche ai
piedi questa roba mi sembra
un'esagerazione effettivamente però
diciamo san marino il suo ace ma giorno
siamo qua house party
siamo a casa ibridi brittney griner
manca la g esatto dire mi fai arrossire
sei veramente incredibile seguimi in
cucina va bene non me lo faccio a
ripeterlo ma certo diamo presto c'era
scritto ho il mio cavaliere
nell'armatura splendente devo stare
attento alle coop che non so cosa sia
immagino sia queste parole pensare che
noi magari intende di non sporcare
giusta meno ha detto semplicemente che
dobbiamo stare attenti che non prenda
fuoco tutto va beh ma tanto noi siamo i
migliori nomi che si sino a camminare
problema anzi a maso serata via mi
chiamo un cucchiaio scusa cioè in una
democrazia dove la zia non c'è più
nessuno sapeva
ansa story non lo sapevo c'è la canzone
sopra va bene non può stare che abbiamo
portato era fatto storico degli esordi
ci mancherebbe anzi guarda che è triste
non so perso un altro adesso che ci sta
pensando
io non ho capito che devo fare è stato
su salsa mi capirà adesso posso tornare
sul secondo te o aspettiamo qua ma io
torni nei su è però se torniamo su
magari che ne so ho paura di rob è
permesso
vabbè vista li stanno rispetto che sei
ancora lì a canalis hanno visto
l'artista non l'ho vista più usati usato
quelle già chiuso medici tutto il tempo
della renault si è accorta che io sono
non ve n'è accorta come fai a percorso
in serie a col presidente
andiamo rabbit nei propri torniamo alla
prima d'ora gli dici che si può ma ha
detto che aveva finito non sono
sbagliato eccola la zia che comunque la
seconda in realtà è vestita come prima e
non è vestita l'esatto wake me up before
you non so la caccia al tesoro che sta
facendo ai piatti
impiattare al 20 minuti dopo ha cucinato
il cucchiaio ok siamo siamo più comfort
folle e allora britney cosa salva sco a
dimmi tutto sei molto di più di quello
che non so quando noi dice ma sei molto
ripidi quello che dicono gli occhi ai
just a parte di lei private si pensi
arriviamo a questo punto schiacciamo
hijas parte ha proprio niente se non so
se va a finire come pensa ma nel caso
c'è anche se censurato accensione del
mondo ovviamente ok ha detto non lo so
però mi ci sta imitando di sopra di
magari quella strana perché a scacchi si
muove ricordo
addio cosa è successo che schifo no no
ho vomitato
ma se invece la scomunica aveva cucinato
crema o no no assurdo faceva schifo
quello che aveva cucinato no dai
vediamo se ci ha ricaricato una roba
abbastanza dagli mica era caricata una
roba abbastanza i premi ma non so forse
ancora sopra si ok
eccola la apple torna senza sabati si
sia dato tutto bene ora aspettiamo bravo
mamma mia che velocità nella tratta
della dei mamma mia
madonna più di una volta
il ces è giusto dai siamo accesso cosa
si è mangiato le ginocchia
cosa sta succedendo che non si può
imitare in eccesso e si vedono prima
problema mica che cazzo ad uno stop non
ha uno stomaco o non ha uno stomaco lui
oa lei ha cucinato con l'olio del motore
veramente se siamo seduti brom e ma
prima l'ho fatto sono morto ah ok devo
prendere qualcosa per proteggere il mio
stomaco capito un anche grazie perché
solo protettiva minchia lo trovo nel
bagno andiamo nel bagno nel bagno
celebri ne facevano uscire la zia i casi
anzi la quale non uscirà anche vengo io
ok perfetto allora pastiglie per non
vomitare ma pastiglie per sopportare
quello che cucina brin nei aspetto tv la
porta sono menati pò c'è qualcosa è
ormai troppo tardi troppo tardi
e difficilissimo ci sia altra parte che
palle
però non stiamo svendendo
momento no perché non sto parlando si
trincera dopo lo sgombero perchè qua non
c'è niente quel trend assolutamente sia
per l'aspetto il coso lo specchio cioè
per ma non si no guarda male a stare
dietro la porta
te lo dicevo prima te ma già premio
killer non è un livello di timo alanne
ai brand cielo per prendere per prima e
la seconda studente ragazzi
chiudi painkiller non si comprende se la
prende anche il pontile che cacchio devo
fare io qua ci facciamo una doccia calda
e fredda scusa mi spetta l'idea che
vediamo nei guai del rubinetto
vedi che non sia nel bagno del bagno di
weimar no inspect e no non puoi farci
niente acqua ma che problema c'è filippo
la porta non si può vedere dai sentite
pangma dei ragazzi ci ho provato e ci
abbiamo però abbiamo provato era molto
complicato devo dire noi negli
appuntamenti comitiva si sempre si
vomita e soprattutto lega non mangia
mangia tese fa schifo leggera senza il
becco citato come l'olio della uefa
cucino io ancora più schifo però almeno
se può mito mi offendo da sola cambiano
e non ci sono problemi per il video di
se questa è la vedo un po strane ma che
cazzo
era il video po particolare ma si gioca
ad house party però non so come si
cucina neanche però non fare incazzare
frank perché non bevo spero che vi sia
piaciuto come 61 cesac del cmb e noi
come sempre signori ci vediamo hanno
proseguito ma stava anche dal canale
dineykin descrizione iscriviti al canale
ciao
[Musica]